this morning our pushing the limit
series meets a canadian woman who is the
first person ever to complete the
trans-canada trail at more than 16 000
miles it is the longest trail in the
whole wide world spanning hundreds of
walking paths roads and waterways deanne
whalen made the journey over six years
by foot by bicycle and by boat and our
jamie wax caught up with her to talk
about what she's learned
they say to get to know someone
you must walk a mile in their shoes
but to really know deanne whalen and
what she's seen over the past six years
that track would take more than sixteen
thousand miles you journeyed
to three oceans from the atlantic ocean
to the pacific ocean to the arctic ocean
yeah actually it went atlantic arctic
and then pacific in 2015 the 56 year old
filmmaker set out for her hardest
expedition yet traveling the entire
trans-canada trail alone so long in fact
if you were to crisscross the united
states five times you still wouldn't
cover the distance of the trans-canada
trail
the solo pilgrimage is the subject of
weyland's next documentary there's
something very fragile about being alone
out on lake superior or deep in the
woods after a while there's something
that wakes up inside you and you
suddenly feel more connected to life
than you've ever been do you come out of
the low depths of loneliness and
isolation into that moment i never
really was lonely on this journey i felt
a strong sense of connection to the
world that was around me the web of life
i went on this journey not as to prove
some sort of athletic accomplishment in
fact by day 10 i realized jamie that i
hadn't even gone as far as i thought i
could go in one day really right so i
burned my schedule
and i joke with people that that's the
day i dropped the rabbit suit for the
turtle shell
and you know surrendered to how long the
journey was going to take me
no schedule to follow allowed waylon to
travel on her own terms taking breaks
when she needed a rest
when the weather was too dangerous
day 50.
through her lens she captured the rugged
pathways and the tools she needed to
navigate the land
the water and at times the treacherous
conditions on average she spent about
eight months on the trail each year
nice to meet you nice to be on your land
along the way weyland crossed paths with
strangers so she said never failed to
offer her a helping hand
and spent time in indigenous communities
whose ancestral land she was traveling
on that's where i actually found my hope
jamie
in learning a different way of different
relationship to the earth instead of
living on it living with it in a lot of
indigenous communities they think about
seven generations
every time you're making a decision you
think about seven generations into the
future how radical that would be if we
brought that into the corporate
boardroom or into government we're
telling our kids we care
on august 1st whalen's journey finally
came to an end her family and the new
friend she met traveling walked with her
hand in hand as she became the first
person and woman to complete the entire
trail what did it feel like on mile zero
i was definitely crying
and it wasn't because my journey was
over
it was because of all the kindness of
people when you watch the news sometimes
you're quite certain that the whole
world's full of sociopaths and it's not
i put myself in a very vulnerable
position being out there alone for as
long as i was and i met a lot of people
and not once did i not meet kindness on
my journey weyland's next journey
sharing the wisdom she learned on her
adventures in a new book and documentary
both titled 500 days in the wild
nature is a place that we could all turn
to through our isolation to fine healing
i definitely found my hope in human
kindness
all across this land and in what
connects us we're you know
for all of our differences we're all
connected by this land and by the water
we are one for cbs mornings i'm jamie
wax in new york